1er février 1957
guy laroche ouvre sa maison de couture
dans un petit appartement
il s'impose déjà comme novateur par les
tissus du soir entièrement perlé par les
couleurs opposées est osé mais pas
d'excentricité pour lui ce n'est pas
synonyme d'élégance mode hors mode c'est
à dire éternel gérer inventé aussi des
tissus par des incrustations de carreaux
ou de rayures les couleurs sont très
acide et pastels des jaunes des verts
or guy laroche encore novateur il veut
démocratiser la haute couture il crée en
61 dans sa maison de prêt-à-porter
couturier aujourd'hui ne doit plus être
un couturier seulement pour une certaine
catégorie de femmes une certaine classe
il doit justement être un couturier au
tout laisse donc sa vie plusieurs
récompenses et surtout de des doors qui
couronne une grande carrière le voici le
lendemain de sa remise lui des doors 89
sa dernière apparition je crois que ça
c'est pour ça que la mode est à paris
c'est parce qu'il ya toujours un serbe
une certaine atmosphère un vent qui fait
qu'on se tout en se cachant car personne
ne sait ce que fait l'autre couturier
mais il se retrouve des idées collier
l'avez vous lu jusqu'au bout accomplir
ce qu'il appelait son de boire dernier
défilé mais aussi dernier hommage rendu
à tous ceux qui ont travaillé avec lui
la mort de guy laroche il était un de
ceux qui font le plus pour la réputation
de la france à l'étranger c'était l'un
des plus grands des grands couturiers
le mois dernier il avait encore reçu le
des doors de la haute couture
yauba grégoire 1er février 1957
guy laroche ouvre sa maison de couture
dans un petit appartement
il s'impose déjà comme novateur par les
tissus robe du soir entièrement perlé
par les couleurs opposées est osé mais
pas d'excentricité pour lui ce n'est pas
synonyme d'élégance mode hors mode c'est
à dire éternel gérer inventé aussi des
tissus par des incrustations de carreaux
de rayures des couleurs sont très acide
et pastels des jaunes des faits guy
laroche encore novateur il veut
démocratiser la haute couture il crée en
61 sa maison de prêt à porter couturier
aujourd'hui ne doit plus être à
couturier seulement pour une certaine
catégorie de femmes une certaine classe
il doit justement être un couturier au
tout les faits dans sa vie plusieurs
récompenses et surtout deux des doors
qui couronne une grande carrière le
voici le lendemain de sa remise du des
doors 89
sa dernière apparition je crois que ça
c'est pour ça que la mode est à paris
c'est parce qu'il ya toujours un certain
serre dans l'atmosphère un vent qui fait
que tout en se cachant car personne ne
sait ce que fait l'autre couturier mais
il se retrouve des idées collier l'avez
vous lu jusqu'au bout accomplir ce qu'il
appelait son devoir dernier défilé mais
aussi dernier hommage rendu à tous ceux
qui ont travaillé avec lui